so what I want to I want you to watch
what she does
right hand up yeah don't worry about BR
your hand up okay so this will be a hard
wall so if he pushes in she will have
there what I call a hard wall it doesn't
feel like a pushing into a marshmallow
should feel like you're pushing into a
marshmallow okay come back so you see a
lot more than you actually see and I'm
going explain it again
all right so what Noel is doing I'm
going to show her now thank
you what she's doing is slow motion
she's coming in and she's going
out you would have seen it but you might
not have known you s it so she comes in
and then she goes
out so that's wrong it's not wrong
technically because you need to take him
over but what I need it
is I need to be at peace all right so I
need him you know he should better feel
like he can go
past are you looking at the body the
push and the pool so when you block your
pushing you are putting and when you're
ping and you want to find that limit
between the push and the pool so we're
still doing a push push movement but
it's a pool
sensation no no thank
you hour but but you've got to be you
got to start somewhere so you've got to
work out look I'm going to do it
hopefully
wrong so I pushed out so when he pushes
into me for that harsh
hardness I don't want to lose you see I
don't want to lose
so I didn't lose by going in it was
suddenly R me any I went like I went the
sh but if I go
like this you see I didn't disturb him
at
all
coming so it's a soft so mean it's a
soft
wall that's why you didn't pay for today
because no I'm not I'm not joking I
didn't want you to say I paid for
that it's it's really it's deep stuff
but what it's trying to say is
if you can go away from here and start
thinking do you know I've noticed I am
too close oh I'm know it's like you know
if we do grip if we do she Naggy and we
go like this he'll feel that hardness
but I can do this
keeping I can do that keeping that same
lightness of what I call the soft wall
so here's the hard wall feel that hard
okay or I can just keep that soft
wall so when cyto Sensi used when you
was Uki for cyto Sensei you never felt
this wow you know way throw some people
that the really good UK is but you
always chose me for the strong the
strongest techniques Tony and he just
called me out cuz he wanted to show them
how this he kept often used to say this
is the most powerfulest man on the
tatami you know he and I grab him behind
or in front or cuish him and all that
and the next thing you know you're up oh
where is he he's throwing you but it's
like this
massive it's an odd power it's a massive
power but it's not a hurting power it's
not like oh a nikk you know it's like a
it's like a massive if you know these
big dumpy bags that they bring sand in
to your house from the trucks it's like
that sort of Landing you it's a sort of
a a a big Power not a what called a
small sharp
power
so I've had to think how did he do it
well he showed me his knuckles these
Knuckles and he said don't do Yono Tony
looked at my Knuckles through doing Yono
when I was young and his these two
Knuckles had moved back in his hand he
said that's how much I've tried doing
yon over the years he said you don't
need that so he taught me that you've
got to find a gentle way because the
technique is strong so so anyhow so uh
have a drink and
then everybody seems okay so far any on
what we're doing I mean there's lots
more to do but but but if any you might
get let's do it again you might get a oh
no that W right let's do it again
no that w't right that's cuz you're
trying to get in all the right places
but when
you when you're in the right place and
you'll go God that felt wonderful you
only need one of them and that'll
inspire you to keep going rich quick
question soft wall hard wall yeah as
you're standing there now if uh if I
said can you can you put hard wall in
yourself or soft wall in yourself what
would you do in your body or mind to
change how you
feel right so that's a good question I
don't I don't right because if I do then
I'm
nuggy do you see what I mean if I have
to create mass or I have to think power
then I'm dominating I'm
nay as far as I'm concerned I reverse
complete roles and I'm UK all the
time you know I put my hand out there
but I'm actually offering it rather than
saying right it's my turn now you buried
me I'm burying you you know so we've
been through that all of you have been
doing it a long time you know you
the you just make the you just make the
path of
nonresistance and it doesn't matter you
know who holds you
it doesn't matter who holds
you see I could only move where he
allowed me to
move look here because he's I've Got to
Now
move that way for it to
work if I wanted to do it technically
I'd go
so by being UK by me being UK if he
needs me to go this way I'll go all
right that's where you need me to go so
I'm completely governed by whatever he
allows me